para realizar este y otros temas
relacionados con el fútbol le damos la
bienvenida a Sara Castro directora del
diario as Colombia y la sección de
deportes de Caracol radio bienvenida
Sara un gusto estar con ustedes Muchas
gracias Sara vamos a hablar de la
selección de Inglaterra esta selección
que dirige Gareth sogate y que arrancan
de buena manera el proceso a la Euro
2024 pero podríamos decir que este es el
último tren de careto Gate y Esta
generación de jugadores para ganar un
gran torneo Pues a mí me gusta mucho
esta Inglaterra yo creo que además la
imagen que nos dejó en el mundial es
bastante positiva por esa mezcla no solo
digamos funcional en cuanto al fútbol
sino que yo creo que también hizo un
recambio que es fundamental en las
elecciones de manera interesante el
hecho de que saca y que entiendan de una
manera tan importante quevelingham
también está entrando en ese circuito de
juego Creo que hace que esta Inglaterra
nos llame mucho la atención en el primer
partido de esta fecha venció a Italia
una Italia que evidentemente pues lastre
de no haber clasificado al mundial pero
que es la actual campeona de la Eurocopa
y le vimos un muy buen funcionamiento
aprovecha muy bien las transiciones sabe
jugar en velocidad y creo que eso es
suficiente
de Italia que no vamos a comentar mucho
pero creo que es súper llamativo lo de
retegui la convocatoria este jugador
argentino que no estaba en los planes de
nadie que anotó un gol frente a
Inglaterra a pesar de la derrota y
también hoy ante Malta Así que hay que
ponerle mucha atención a este jugador
juega en tigre de Argentina Así que se
pinta como como una de esas de esos
como decirlo ese ojo claro y sobre todo
el ojo que tiene manchini porque nadie
lo tenía en estos planes una Italia que
le costó mucho a las lesiones después de
ganar esa Euro y que evidentemente
estará en carrera también otro equipo
que estará jugando por este lunes es la
selección de Francia vencieron cuatro
por cero Países Bajos en su primera
presentación y en su segundo partido
enfrentarán como visitante a Irlanda
Sara qué decir de esta selección de
Francia que
ve como algunos jugadores dan un paso al
costado pero no desentona mantiene ese
ritmo arrollador sí impresionante yo
creo que esto habla primero un de chams
que llega con una renovación de cuatro
años esto habla de que hay un proyecto
francés que cree en el entrenador y
también en lo que hacen estos jugadores
se dio un paso muy importante que era el
cambio de la capitanía sin lloris se
dudaba si iba a ser para griezmann o
para mbappé el entrenador decide darse
el mbappé y creo que ese partido frente
a Holanda pues frente a Países Bajos
dejó muy claro que es un equipo que está
bien
engranado y que sobre todo se entienden
vimos muy buenas actuaciones el equipo
fue arrollador evidentemente un país es
bajos que estaba diezmado por unas bajas
por un virus estomacal que sufrieron
varios de sus jugadores yo creo que este
Francia Insisto que tiene este proyecto
este proyecto del fútbol francés que
mezcla no solo estas diferentes clases
de fútbol y de biotipo que tienen sus
jugadores sino que yo creo que va a
pintar para muchas cosas para para mí es
fundamental que después de una caída
tanto dolorosa como la de Qatar la de
lucely siga teniendo esto es un equipo
que junta muchos hombres en ataque que
con espacios es implacable que tiene
muchísima velocidad y un griezmann que
si bien no tiene la capitanía lo vimos
en el mundial y lo estamos viendo en
Atlético de Madrid es un jugador un
todocampista un jugador que está
marcando muy bien los tiempos y que es
el enlace que siempre ha necesitado esta
selección francesa ahora vamos a hablar
de Brasil porque el pasado 25 de marzo
cayó en un partido amistoso frente a
Marruecos dos goles por uno su técnico
en este compromiso fue Ramón Meneses
quien presuntamente está de manera
interina y decimos presuntamente de
manera interina porque sabemos lo que
pasa con los interinatos en Sudamérica
Sara Más allá de Meneses quién podría
asumir las riendas de este combinado
brasileño se habla mucho de Carlos
ancelotti pero podría ser una realidad
la llegada del técnico del Madrid Pues
la verdad es que solo son rumores
algunos jugadores han demostrado su
interés en que sea Carlo ancelotti el
entrenador que llegue a dirigir esta
selección brasilera y yo creo que en
este caso Ramón Meneses sí es un técnico
interino y por eso es tan difícil sacar
conclusiones de un partido como este
porque sin tener claro hacia dónde se va
era muy complicado poder entender que
era lo que se pretendía evidentemente lo
que hizo Meneses fue darle el rodaje
jugadores como Arthur virtual Roque que
van a estar en el mundial sub-20 algunos
jugadores debutaron en esta selección
brasilera se le dio la oportunidad a
futbolistas del ámbito local pero
evidentemente pues no tenían mucho más
que pelear un partido más o menos
competitivo evidentemente del otro lado
si estaba Marruecos un equipo que además
tuvo 60.000 personas animándolo en el
estadio y que lo vimos competir en el
mundial de una manera muy importante en
el mundial se les cuestionó un poco que
evidentemente eran defensivos porque era
la manera de protegerse ante equipos de
élite con mucho más rodaje en términos
de mundiales ayer se los vio un fútbol
mucho más ofensivo volvemos a ver a
hakimi a un ají y a sillek por esa banda
derecha rabat en el medio campo yo creo
que este Marruecos va a dar mucho de que
hablar con un técnico como regraga que
evidentemente ha podido encontrar esas
soluciones tácticas a un equipo que no
tiene con los que nos cuenta con los
mismos recursos que otros equipos de
gran nivel de Brasil yo creo que hay que
darle espera y lo que sí
se está esperando en territorio
brasilero es que ya para los amistosos
de junio a tres años del próximo mundial
ya tengan el entrenador que pueda dar
las líneas de lo que va a hacer este
nuevo proceso
tita dejó un trabajo importante pero
para Brasil quedar eliminado en cuartos
de final sigue siendo un golpe muy muy
doloroso Así que veremos Cómo
reencaminan y sobre todo pues con una
selección que tiene muchísimo talento
pero que necesita conseguir resultados y
había mucha esperanza en esa selección
Sara Muchísimas gracias por este amplio
análisis del Fútbol Internacional un